> TODAY THE UNITED STATES
WARNED RUSSIA IT WOU FACE,
QUOTE, SEVERE CONSEQUENCES IF IT
WERE TO USE A RADIOACTIVE DIRTY
BOMB IN UKRAINE.
THE THREAT CAMAFTER WESTERN
ALLIES REJECTED CLAIMS BY TOP
RUSSIAN MILITARY OFFICIAL THAT
UKRAINE WAS PLANNING TO USE A
DIRTY BOMB.
MORE ON THAT STORY IN A MOMENT.
>>> WE FIRST WANT TO GIVE A FEW
MINUTES ON THE STATE OF THE WAR
IN THE SOUTH OF UKRAINE AROUND
THE STRATEGICALLY IMPORTANT CITY
OF KHERSON.
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS SAY RUSSIA
BROUGHT MORE MILITARY UNITS
THERE TODAY, AND RUSSIAN
MISSILES STRUCK THE NEARBY CITY
OF MYKOLAIV THIS WEEKEND.
THAT'S WHERE CNN CHIEF
INTERNATIONAL CORRESPONDENT
CLARISSA WARD IS TONIGHT.
SHE'S FOCUSING ON THE PLIGHT OF
CIVILIANS IN BOTH CITIES.
>> Reporter: BY NOW, IT HAS
BECOME A FAMILIAR ROUTINE IN
MYKOLAIV.
IN THE RELATIVE CALM OF DAYLIGHT
HOURS, RESIDENTS COMB THROUGH
THE WRECKAGE OF THE NIGHT
BEFORE.
ON THIS DAY, IT'S AN APARTMENT
BUILDING ON THE OUTSKIRTS OF
TOWN.
TWO RUSSIAN S-300 MISSILES HIT
AT 1:00 IN THE MORNING.
SO THIS HERE IS WHERE THE FIRST
STRIKE HIT, AND THEN YOU CAN SEE
THE SECOND ONE JUST SMASHED INTO
THE TOP OF THAT BUILDING.
FIVE PEOPLE WERE INJURED, BUT
MIRACULOUSLY, NO ONE WAS KILLED.
IN ONE APARTMENT, ANDREI IS BUSY
CLEANING UP.
HE TELLS US THIS IS WHAT THE
RUSSIANS DO.
THEY SHOOT NOT AT MILITARY
OBJECTS BUT WHERE PEOPLE LIVE,
HE SAYS.
THE FACT IS THE ANGER TOWARDS
THEM IS RISING, AND IT WON'T GO
AWAY, NOT IN A MONTH, NOT IN A
YEAR, NOT EVEN TEN YEARS.
IN THIS SOUTHERN PORT CITY,
PEOPLE HAVE BECOME USED TO
HARDSHIP.
SINCE APRIL, THERE HAS BEEN NO
FRESH WATER HERE.
THE MAIN PUMPING STATION WAS HIT
IN A RUSSIAN STRIKE.
NOW THEY GATHER EVERY DAY AND
PATIENTLY WAIT TO STOCK UP.
A FEW BLOCKS DOWN, ANOTHER LINE,
THIS ONE FOR HUMANITARIAN AID.
"WILL I BE ABLE TO GET SOMETHING
TODAY?"
THIS OLD WOMAN ASKS.
"WE ALREADY HAVE 100 PEOPLE ON
THE LIST," THE ORGANIZER
REPLIES.
MYKOLAIV IS LESS THAN 20 MILES
FROM THE NEAREST FRONT LINES AND
JUST 35 MILES FROM THE
RUSSIAN-HELD CITY OF KHERSON.
LAST WEEK, RUSSIA ANNOUNCED THAT
CIVILIANS MUST LEAVE KHERSON,
WARNING OF AN IMMINENT UKRAINIAN
ATTACK.
UKRAINE CALLED IT PROPAGANDA TO
DISTRACT FROM RECENT UKRAINIAN
MILITARY GAINS.
IT IS DIFFICULT TO GET A PICTURE
OF WHAT'S REALLY GOING ON IN
KHERSON, BUT WE MANAGED TO
CONNECT WITH ONE RESIDENT WHO WE
WILL CALL VITALI, WHO TOOK THESE
VIDEOS.
THE STREETS, HE SAYS, ARE EMPTY,
BUT THERE ARE PEOPLE IN THE
MARKETS.
MOST VENDORS NO LONGER WANT TO
TAKE RUSSIAN RUBLES AS THEY
PREPARE FOR A POTENTIAL RUSSIAN
WITHDRAWAL.
DO YOU HAVE A SENSE OF WHETHER
RUSSIAN FORCES HAVE LEFT THE
CITY OR NOT?
>> Translator: THERE ARE FEWER
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS HERE, BUT YOU
FIND THEM AROUND THE CITY.
SEVERAL DAYS AGO, THERE WAS A
ROTATION, AND THEY BROUGHT IN
NEW SOLDIERS.
PART OF THE SOLDIERS WHO WERE
HERE FOR A WHILE, THEY LEFT, AND
THE NEW ONES CAME.
PROBABLY THEY ARE MOBILIZED,
CONSCRIPTS.
THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT CITY
THEY'RE IN.
>> AND WHY DID YOU DECIDE TO
STAY?
ARE YOU NOT FRIGHTENED?
>> Translator: IT'S OUR CITY.
WE BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE TO WAIT
UNTIL OUR ARMY COMES.
I CAN'T SAY WE ARE NOT AFRAID.
WE ARE AFRAID.
BUT THIS IS OUR DECISION.
>> Reporter: THE PEOPLE WHO
REMAIN IN MYKOLAIV HAVE MADE A
SIMILAR DECISION.
BACK AT THE STRIKE SITE, THE
CLEANUP HAS ALREADY BEGUN AS THE
CITY BRACES ITSELF FOR THE NEXT
ATTACK.
>> CLARISSA JOINS US NOW FROM
MYKOLAIV.
JUST TO SEE THAT LITTLE BOY
CLEANING UP, IT'S JUST SO SAD.
THE PHYSICAL HARDSHIPS, THE
THREATS ARE CLEARLY TAKING A
TOLL.
HOW ARE PEOPLE STEELING
THEMSELVES FOR WHAT REMAINS TO
COME?
>> Reporter: WELL, I MEAN WE
JUST HEARD TONIGHT FROM
PRESIDENT VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY,
ANDERSON, SAYING THAT UKRAINIANS
SHOULD PREPARE THEMSELVES FOR
THE TOUGHEST WINTER YET.
AND BASED ON WHAT WE'VE BEEN
SEEING ON THE GROUND, IT IS
GOING TO BE A VERY GRIM WINTER
INDEED.
THERE'S COMPLETE BLACKOUT AS YOU
CAN SEE BEHIND ME, AND A CURFEW.
THAT'S NOT BECAUSE OF THE HITS
ON THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT'S BECAUSE OF SECURITY
REASONS, BECAUSE MYKOLAIV IS
GETTING HIT SO OFTEN.
BUT THAT IS BEING COMPOUNDED BY
THE FACT THAT YOU DO NOW HAVE
ROLLING BLACKOUTS, VERY LIMITED
USE OF ELECTRICITY, NO FRESH
WATER SINCE APRIL.
PEOPLE HERE REALLY HAVE TO BATHE
OR TAKE SHOWERS IN SALTED WATER.
SO IT'S CLEARLY NOT A
SUSTAINABLE SITUATION, BUT AT
THE SAME TIME, PEOPLE JUST DON'T
WANT TO LEAVE THEIR HOMES.
THEY DON'T WANT TO LEAVE THEIR
PROPERTY.
WE MET A LOT OF PEOPLE LIKE
ANDREI, THE MAN WHO WAS CLEANING
UP HIS APARTMENT, WHO SAY
THEY'VE SENT THEIR FAMILIES AWAY
FOR THEIR OWN SECURITY, BUT
THEY'RE DETERMINED TO WAIT HERE
UNTIL THE BITTER END.
AND BASED ON EVERYTHING WE'VE
SEEN AND EVERYTHING WE'RE
HEARING AND THE DIRECTION THINGS
ARE MOVING IN AS WE GET INTO
WINTER AND RUSSIA CONTINUES TO
POUND CIVILIAN INFRASTRUCTURE,
IT IS GOING TO BE BITTER INDEED,
ANDERSON.
>> CLARISSA WARD, BE CAREFUL.
THANK YOU.
>>> NEXT, THE THREAT WE
MENTIONED ABOUT THE POSSIBLE USE
OF A DIRTY BOMB.
RUSSIA'S CLAIM WITHOUT EVIDENCE
THAT UKRAINE WAS PREPARING TO
USE.
WHAT IS ESSENTIALLY A DEVICE
THAT CONTAINS CONVENTIONAL
EXPLOSIVES ALONG WITH
RADIOACTIVE MATERIALS.
THERE ARE CONCERNS RUSSIA IS
MAKING A CLAIM AS A JUSTCATION
TO ESCALATE THE WAR OR PERHAPS
USE SUCH A BOMB THEMSELVES.
PERSPECTIVE FROM NATIONAL
SECURITY SPOKESPERSON JOHN
KIRBY.
ADMIRAL KIRBY, APPRECIATE YOU
JOINING US.
HOW CONCERNED IS THE UNITED
STATES AND NATO ABOUT THESE
DIRTY BOMB ALLEGATIONS THAT
RUSSIA IS MAKING AGAINST
UKRAINE?
>> IT'S DEEPLY CONCERNING AND I
THINK YOU CAN PICK UP THE TONE
AND TENOR FROM THE READOUT THE
PENTAGON GAVE AFTER SECRETARY
AUSTIN'S CALL WITH HIS RUSSIAN
COUNTERPART.
CERTAINLY WE KNOW THAT THESE ARE
FAULTS ALLEGATIONS.
THERE IS NO SUCH DIRTY BOMB
PLANNED BY THE UKRAINIANS.
THAT'S JUST FALSE.
BUT THAT THE RUSSIANS WOULD
RAISE IT AT THEIR REQUEST, THEY
INITIATED THAT PHONE CALL,
CERTAINLY GIVES US PAUSE FOR
CONCERN.
I WILL TELL YOU, ANDERSON, WE
WATCH THIS AS CLOSELY AS WE CAN,
INCLUDING TODAY, AND WE'VE JUST
NOT SEEN ANY KIND OF
PREPARATIONS MOVING IN THAT
REGARD RIGHT NOW.
>> WHAT SORT OF PREPARATIONS --
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN SAY, BUT
WHAT SORT OF PREPARATIONS WOULD
ONE SEE OR COULD ONE SEE OF A
PREPARATION FOR A DIRTY BOMB
ATTACK?
>> YEAH.
LOOK, YOU WOULD EXAMINE ALL
KINDS OF DIFFERENT SOURCES OF
INTELLIGENCE, BOTH FROM THE
UKRAINIANS ON THE GROUND AS WELL
AS OTHER WAYS THAT YOU CAN KIND
OF DIVINE SOME INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT THE RUSSIANS MAY BE
PLANNING TO DO AND HOW THEY'RE
PREPARING FOR IT.
IT COULD RANGE FROM THE WAY
THEY'RE TALKING TO ONE ANOTHER
TO SORT OF THE RANGE OF ACTUAL
PHYSICAL MOVEMENT.
AND, AGAIN, WE'RE WATCHING THIS
VERY, VERY CLOSELY, AND WE'RE
JUST NOT SEEING ANYTHING THAT
WOULD GIVE US PAUSE RIGHT NOW TO
THINK THAT THIS KIND OF AN
ATTACK OR THIS KIND OF FALSE
FLAG WOULD BE IMMINENT.
>> THIS DOES SEEM SOMETHING OUT
OF THE RUSSIAN PLAYBOOK.
I FEEL LIKE WE HAVE SEEN THIS
BEFORE FROM RUSSIA.
>> IT IS NOT UNCOMMON FOR THE
RUSSIANS TO BLAME OTHERS FOR
WHAT THEY ARE DOING OR WHAT THEY
ARE PLANNING TO DO, WHICH IS
AGAIN WHY, YOU KNOW, WE TOOK THE
CALL SERIOUSLY AND MADE THAT
PUBLIC FOR WHAT THE RUSSIANS
WERE ALLEGING.
AND IT WASN'T JUST US.
THE BRITS, THE FRENCH, AND OTHER
COUNTRIES AS WELL MADE THAT
PUBLIC.
SO IT IS OF A PIECE OF THE KINDS
OF FALSE FLAG PRETEXT OPERATIONS
THAT THE RUSSIANS ARE KNOWN FOR.
AGAIN, THAT'S WHAT GIVES US THE
CONCERN.
>> DOES THE U.S. CURRENTLY HAVE
THE DIPLOMATIC CHANNELS TO BE
ABLE TO COMMUNICATE WITH RUSSIA
IN THE EVENT OF SOME SORT OF
NUCLEAR CRISIS?
>> YES, INDEED WE DO.
WE STILL HAVE AN EMBASSY IN
MOSCOW, AND WE CERTAINLY HAVE
COMMUNICATIONS WITH OUR RUSSIAN
COUNTERPARTS BOTH AT THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT AND AT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT.
AND THERE'S ALSO A DECONFLICTION
CHANNEL WHICH IS USED MORE FOR
TACTICAL STUFF AROUND THE
EASTERN FLANK OF NATO THAT'S SET
UP IN EUROPE AT EUROPEAN COMMAND
TO SPEAK TO THE RUSSIANS AT THAT
LEVEL.
SO THERE ARE MULTIPLE WAYS OF
COMMUNICATING, AND IT'S
IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW, AS WE'VE
SAID THROUGHOUT THE LAST EIGHT
MONTHS, THAT WHILE WE DON'T WANT
BUSINESS AS USUAL WITH RUSSIA,
WE BELIEVE IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
OUR BILATERAL COMMUNICATIONS TO
STAY OPEN.
>> TODAY THERE WAS A GROUP OF 30
HOUSE DEMOCRATS WHO SENT A
LETTER TO PRESIDENT BIDEN URGING
WHAT THEY CALLED A PROACTIVE
DIPLOMATIC PUSH TO SEEK A
CEASE-FIRE.
LAST WEEK IN AN INTERVIEW, HOUSE
MINORITY LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY
SUGGESTED A REPUBLICAN HOUSE
WOULD BE LESS WILLING TO PROVIDE
AID TO UKRAINE.
IS THE WHITE HOUSE CONCERNED
ABOUT BEING ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT UKRAINE NEEDS OR
WANTS?
>> WE'VE BEEN GETTING TERRIFIC
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, BOTH SIDES
OF THE AISLE, FOR THE LAST EIGHT
MONTHS, EVEN BEYOND THAT.
AND CERTAINLY THERE'S STRONG
PUBLIC SUPPORT FOR SUPPORTING
UKRAINE.
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THAT, AND THE
PRESIDENT'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH CONGRESS GOING
FORWARD.
I'M NOT GOING TO GET AHEAD OF
THE MIDTERMS AND HOW THINGS
MIGHT OR MIGHT NOT SHAKE OUT.
WE BELIEVE THERE'S STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR
SUPPORTING UKRAINE, AND WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THAT'S GOING TO
CHANGE APPRECIABLY GOING
FORWARD.
I THINK EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS
NOT JUST ON CAPITOL HILL BUT
THROUGHO